Speaker 1: Welcome back to the show producer Pat
Forde filling in for David today as he continues
his paternity leave. So Joe Biden is weighing
whether to set in place a gas tax holiday in
response to the ballooning gas prices, which
have actually come down a little bit in recent
days. And I'll get to that in a second. But as
I'm sure many of you know, there's a federal
gasoline tax. It's 18.3 cents per gallon. And so
the money goes towards restoring roads and bridges
all across the country. But with prices of
gasoline at around $5 a gallon right now,
there's this idea floating that maybe it would
be a good idea to provide temporary relief to
Americans who are feeling it at the pump and
suspend the gas tax. The decision is supposed to
come from the Joe Biden administration at the end
of the week. However, you really need Congress to
enact this. Biden said that he is also weighing
whether to send Americans gas rebate cards,
saying that that's part of what they're
considering and that's part of the operation.
Previously, the administration said that
it would be too difficult to put in place
a system for gas rebate cards, but
now they're taking another look at it.
When it comes to the gas tax holiday, I get the
sense that if Joe Biden wants it, the Democrats
are going to go along with it and he'll be
able to get the votes, although, you know,
Democrats are often cautious about doing anything
that will do away with, you know, funds for things
like infrastructure. The question is, would
Republicans go along with it, though, because
more than they want to actually fix these issues
surrounding inflation and high gas prices and
the like. They want to have something to attack
Joe Biden on. So they're totally happy, in my
opinion, seeing gas prices go up and up and up
because it gives them a greater chance possibly of
winning in the midterms. So maybe they'll oppose
Joe Biden's tax holiday idea and then turn around
and blame him for the high gas prices. The Triple
A national average for a gallon of gasoline right
now is down to $4.96, which is still exceptionally
high, but it's down from $5.02 a week or so ago.
So this could be a sign that we've reached the
peak, could be a sign that gas prices are going
to trickle down from here on, but it's still
too early to say. And then you think, okay,
if we move towards suspending the federal
gas tax, we're looking at an average of,
you know, $4.78 per gallon or so. That does sound
a lot better. But is it going to make a material
difference for the average American? Because
let's say right now it costs, say, 80 bucks
to fill up your tank. Well, now it's going to go
down about $3. It'll be $77 to fill up your tank,
which I like. Okay. I get it. For the average
people out there just trying to make ends meet,
it could make some difference. Right. But I think
for the most part, this is more about politics.
It's more about making it so that Joe Biden looks
like he's trying to actually solve the issue. And
for some Americans, it just helps sort of at the
psychological level that if you drive by the gas
station, that the numbers are going down a little
bit, that it's now $4.87 instead of $5. That helps
a little bit, right? We have the same conversation
whenever we talk about the idea of taking more oil
out of the Strategic Petroleum Reserve, that it
can do some good. Right. But at the end of the
day, it's only going to save you about $0.10
a gallon, $0.20 a gallon. So is that going to
be a substantial difference for most Americans?
And obviously, a big factor in the high price of
gas right now isn't just the pandemic recovery
and inflation and Putin's war on Ukraine. It's
also greed from the oil and gas companies which
are experiencing record profits at the moment.
Joe Biden said about this that he's going to be
speaking with the oil and gas CEOs, members of his
administration specifically will, so they can get
an explanation as to how they're able to make $35
billion in the first quarter of the year while
the average American is struggling. So that's
the latest on gas prices. They are coming down a
little bit, but they would come down quite a bit
deal more if Joe Biden and the Democrats and the
rest of Congress decide to suspend the gas tax.